[inaudible]
joining me today is the host of
the relatable podcast, a speaker,
a commentator at a cat person, Allie
Stuckey. Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having
me. All right, Stuckey.
I have wanted you in the studio
for quite some time to be here.
It is good to have you here,
but we got,
I got two bones to pick before we do
anything have to do with cats. Number one,
you're a cat person. What's going on? You
just met my dog about, she says, sweet.
I love dogs. I have a dog. She's a
rescue. I have two cats. Cats are just,
they're cool and they're easy.
They don't need that much of your time,
that much of your attention.
I travel a lot like you do and so it's
nice to just be able to leave the cats,
but you got to put a dog in a Kennel.
You got to pay a bunch of money.
They need your time. They need your
attention. They need to go outside.
Cats are cool. They don't really want to
hang out with your plotting to kill you.
Most of the Times you're looking at
you that they could lunge at you at any
moment. Oh, that's a stereotype that I
week expect someone on the left to me,
but that's,
it's not true.
You have to take cats by their individual
personalities and not categorize them.
Look at how you just used identity
politics against me just right. Right.
It applies to the animal kingdom to,
I just needed you to know. All right.
That's number one. Okay. Just going
to have to agree to disagree and dogs.
Number two for about two years I
had the number one Prager u video.
Oh, I left the left. Sorry.
Then you came in there.
You took number one away from me,
but actually I don't know if
you know this as of the last,
cause you could see somebody else took
number one. I don't, I'm not even,
so we need to get them in here and now
we have a bone to pick with them. Yeah.
I actually can't remember who was,
um,
or what even the topic was
this morning and I was like,
I don't even want to know. I don't
even want it now. But you, uh, you was,
what was the title of his masculinity?
I think it was like make men masculine
naked or something like that.
So I guess that was a hot
topic that people really
wanted to hear about. I mean,
it was so fun to make. Obviously
you've made for your, your video too,
but I didn't really anticipate it
being one of those viral videos.
I kind of just thought, okay, most
people in general agree with me,
but the vitriol of course they got you.
You just,
you're continually surprised by
some people on the laugh too,
are so opposed to what are very
traditional ideas. So, yeah. All right,
well we're going to talk about some of
those traditional ideas. We'll tell us,
talk about masculinity and me two and
a whole bunch of other stuff called for
people that don't know you. Yeah. Where
did you come from? What's going on here?
Yes. So I started in this
whole kind of political,
I won't even say media field,
but kind of about three
and a half years ago.
So fall of 2015 I was working in PR,
graduated from college in 2014 PR,
social media just had kind
of your normal agency job.
But in fall of 2015 I lived in
a college town, Athens, Georgia.
And I looked around and
the friends that I had,
both in college and out of college had no
idea what was going on in the election.
It was the primaries.
And I thought these are really smart
people and a lot of them are conservative
in their values and yet they seem to be
touting these progressive use when it
comes to politics and they really
have no idea what's going on.
And so I really just kind of had a,
a random idea when I was driving one
day called my mom and I said, you know,
I think I want to tell sorority girls
why they should vote in the primaries
because they seem so apathetic.
I feel like I can talk to this crap.
Cause I was a story a girl about a year
before that. And so I created this,
it really was a nonpartisan
presentation, um, for,
for college students for why they
should vote in the primaries.
And I started reaching out to add the
sorority presidents and you can find that
information online. I just said, can I
please come? I want to speak for free.
It's going to be nonpartisan.
I just want to tell you guys
why you should vote in the
primaries. And it worked.
I mean,
I started speaking to some of these
groups and then I started getting asked by
other organizations on and
off campus, uh, to come speak.
And then from that I started a blog
and that was called the conservative
millennial ditch,
the nonpartisan thing pretty quickly.
And then after a few months of doing that,
I started making videos and
that's kind of what it took off.
So end of 2016 beginning of 2017 is when
it probably officially became a career,
started working at the blaze. And
then that changed to, I moved to CRTV.
That's where I started my podcast.
And that was the beginning of 28 team.
Yes.
I'm getting my years confused. Beginning
of 2018 that I started the podcast,
so still speak, still
commentate. Um, I still write,
I still do a lot of the same things I
was doing three and a half years ago.
It's just evolved into a full time thing.
Yeah,
it's pretty sweet.
When you start doing something and next
thing you know it becomes something
becomes up. Right, right. Yeah. Not Bad.
Do you come from a political
family or anything?
Did you care about politics before this
or was that just your wake up when you
realize nobody knows what
they're talking about? A college?
I would say both ant mostly.
Mostly the second one I grew up in,
I wouldn't say it was an a political home.
I knew we were conservatives
and I knew we liked the,
the earliest president that I
really remember as George W. Bush,
and I was really young during nine 11
and I remember the patriotism that my
parents showed and that we were supposed
to show that I knew we were supporting
George W. Bush. And we kind of grew
up watching Fox News, but politics,
it wasn't a discussion that we had
at the dinner table necessarily.
I just knew the values that we had.
My parents were entrepreneurs.
They came from very poor
families in Arkansas.
They had no money when they got married.
They were 19 and 20 and they really went
from nothing and then build a business
and built a life for my brothers.
And for me,
that was so much better
than the ones that they had.
And so the idea of freedom
of entrepreneurship,
of not having a cap on your potential
was just always really attractive to me.
So there was never a time in college,
high school,
even as a rebellious teenager,
that I was like, you know,
more government control actually sounds
really good. It just, it just never,
never occurred to me that
would lead to a better life.
I just always loved the entrepreneurial
spirit in the idea of the American dream
that my parents embodied.
So it was more of those values
rather than talking about politics,
my dad did become a state representative,
um, when I was in college,
I think it was 2012. And so yeah,
that probably spurred some interest.
I started probably getting
a more knowledgeable and
more informed about actually
what was going on.
But yeah,
I would say it's more a
lifelong value building thing.
And then by the time I graduated
college, I was like, oh my gosh,
I feel like our nation
is kind of at a crisis.
How does religion play a role in that?
It plays a huge, it plays a huge role.
You know, we hear a lot, especially
from people in the lot, uh,
that you're religious,
you should have,
have no impact on what you
believe politically. Well,
that's just a false idea of,
of religion and a false
idea of your faith.
If your faith is the center of your life,
which religious people believe that
it should be and it's going to affect
everything,
it's going to affect all of your values.
It's going to affect
probably how you vote. Um,
and it's going to affect that the things
that you believe in politically and the
way that you think that the country
should go and so be not only a born again
Christian, but also a
Protestant Christian. Um,
having roots in even the Protestant
reformation and how that kind of affected
the, the movement of the West towards
freedom and towards individual liberty,
I think has certainly been a legacy that
was passed down to me. And it all just,
it all has always made sense.
I wish I had like a better
journey story of changing my mind,
but the idea of individual liberty and
human dignity and all of the rights that
come with that, it just,
it just always made sense.
The stories that come from a little more
of an evolution that they involve more
violence and pain and anger, but there's
Tracy, they make for a good story. Yeah.
They make for a good book. Yeah. Perhaps.
Perhaps. Maybe. I don't know. Um,
so when you got into the online
world and started posting videos,
podcasting and all that,
um,
were you shocked that sort of the tenor
and the way people talk about these
things and all that?
Well,
you know,
when I first started,
when I first started the blog and then
I started doing videos, I mean, one,
I had no money,
no backers,
no idea what I was doing. And the,
I mean, the first videos that I did,
or in my living room, I
have no makeup on, no light,
and using my phone look ridiculous.
Got No views whatsoever.
And so it was after I
persisted for a little bit,
sometimes I look back and I'm like,
why did you even persist?
No one was telling you to,
but you did.
And then it's really the first time
that you get any kind of attention or
affirmation that you also
see the other side of it, uh,
that you also see the negativity when
you're just doing it kind of for yourself.
And for the few people that follow
you, you're like, this is great.
Everyone loves me.
The three people that follow me,
I'll let me and my parents and my
husband love what I do. This is great.
But then as soon as something kind
of blows up, yeah, as they say,
you see the negative side of it,
then you okay.
People don't just disagree with you,
they really hate you and they really
think that you're a bad person.
Especially if you espouse any kind of
faith that immediately comes into question
if you disagree with them.
And that was hard. I mean,
I used to focus on the comments a lot.
You have to stop doing that though.
It's so unhealthy. So that's kind of a,
that's changed over the past few years.
Definitely. But uh, yeah, I think the
hatred threw me for a loop at first.
Yeah. Well it just sort of comes and
you don't really know what to do.
And then at some point, I think I've
come around to the place where it's like,
the more I get, I'm like, oh, I
must be doing something right. Yeah.
People used to lie about what I
was saying and I didn't like that.
Now they actually quote me and
I'm like, Oh, this is actually,
this is what must be feel like when you
made it think it was actually you that
tweeted the other day, some article
by right wing watch was I you and yes,
they did
call on me not that long ago too.
They quoted something that I said at
CRTV and of course everything looks like
it's some hiphop
piece. But then I read it and I'm like,
that's what I, that's what I said.
I was like, this is an actual
basically an honest piece.
Really close as quoted show. Exactly. And
I'm like, if people think that's crazy,
I'm totally fine with that. But
like you said, don't lie about,
don't lie about what I'm saying.
Is it unique to be a woman in this space?
Use a little identity politics here.
I thought Republicans and the right,
I thought they hate women.
You don't listen to women,
don't they subjugate women
who are pregnant,
but I am wearing shoes and so I am,
I've against that part of that.
No, I, I've never, I've never
really understood that argument.
I guess if you equate women's rights
to abortion and to this mythical gender
wage gap that needs to somehow
be filled by the government,
if you equate women's rights to that and
women's empowerment to that, then sure.
Um, I guess the left is
the only place for women.
But if you believe in entrepreneurship,
if you believe in the marketplace,
if you believe that women
have the potential and the
dignity that a man has and
the potential to do everything
that a man does in a way,
at least as far as her career
goes and leadership goes,
then I don't see why you wouldn't
be a conservative. Unfortunately,
we do have a PR problem, uh, on the
right, and I voted for president Trump,
but president Trump doesn't really help
the rights case when it comes to women,
not just because of things
he said and done with women.
But also I think a lot of moms,
especially hear him talk,
hear him at his rallies, he's got a little
bit of a of a mouth and they're like,
I don't, you know, I don't really
want my kids listening to that.
That's not who I want my kids to be.
I wouldn't marry someone like that.
And so I do think that he makes it a
little bit difficult sometimes to make the
case.
Is that the odd catch 22 of
almost everything Trump does?
Cause we talked about this briefly right
before we started where it's like the
policies pretty much make sense then if
you can remove that from the tweets or
the person, it's like he's actually
at a ton of high level limits.
Totally in the administration. If you
care, if that's what you're looking at,
it just makes it more difficult,
I think that you're able to
do it.
But when the left has such a
monopoly on media megaphones,
when they have an monopoly on Hollywood,
they have a monopoly on academia.
I won't say monopoly,
but they're controlling a lot of the
messaging that comes out and they're,
they're good at PR, they're good at the
emotionalism that, not to be sexist,
but appeals to a lot of women.
And so you hear the rhetoric of Trump
is putting kids in cages and he grabs
women by the genitals and you're a woman.
You're like, I can't vote for that.
I can't do that.
And so in order to separate some of the
lies from the truth and separate the
things that Trump has said from the good
things that he's done for men and women,
you have to think and you
have to go a step further.
You have to do your own research.
And a lot of people, male or female,
just don't want to do that.
When you can read headlines
by just swiping your thumb,
why are you going to take the time to
actually click on an article and then
double check it and make
sure that it's right.
It's just harder to be a conservative
for that very reason. Takes more effort.
How do you cut through the clutter? I
mean, that's one of the things that,
especially when I go to colleges,
that kids ask me all the time, like,
how do you actually figure
out what's true? Yeah.
Because reading all of these
articles, it's like, I mean,
we know because they write them
about us, and then it's like, well,
I know what lies that were in there.
So what else?
What else are they lying to us about?
I mean, you really have to try
and go to the source if you can.
If they said that someone says something,
you have to actually go to the actual
quote or the actual video. I mean,
a perfect example of this is when
president Trump, uh, just the other day,
the clip of him saying,
or allegedly saying that asylum
seekers we're animals with circulating.
I'm great. Yeah. It was deceptively
edited. And so in order for you,
someone like Chrissy Tiegen who tweeted
about it and said that, you know,
he's awful. Okay. In order for you
not to believe Chrissy Tiegen for,
in order for you to not believe the
tweets that she quote tweeted, yeah.
You're several Democratic candidates,
by the way. Yes. Yes. Also.
So it's not just Hollywood celebrities,
even though they knew he wasn't,
just to be very clear here, he was not
saying that asylum seekers or animals,
he was specifically talking about yeah.
13 yeah. Which is a totally
appropriate description of them. Um,
but in order to realize that that's a lie,
you have to jump through a lot of hoops.
I mean,
because say I'm someone
on the laughter Sam,
someone in the middle and I see
Dave Rubin or Ben Shapiro say,
that's not really what he said. Well,
why should I believe you anymore?
So you have to go to the actual source.
You have to go to actual reporting.
It's more effort.
That's something that you and I are
probably willing to do because we know the
game that they're playing.
But a lot of people just don't know.
But I also think that's why
people are turning away. Uh,
and especially young people from
mainstream media and from talking heads in
listening to podcasts where there's
conversations and when there was dialogue
where there's nuance and where
people are willing to say, you know,
I don't know that much about this.
Here's what both sides are saying.
You hardly ever see that on the news.
So I think, I think that's part of it.
It's a change in the media landscape.
Yeah.
Where do you think Trump fits in?
I try not to do that much about Trump in
general, but since you brought him up,
yeah.
Um,
where do you think he fits in with sort
of the future of conservatism then? Yeah,
I can sense a little push
and pull with you on him.
Yeah. I mean I voted for him and
I think I'll vote for him again.
It's mostly because I voted for him in
2016 mostly because lesser of two evils
then. I didn't think that he was going
to lead very conservatively. I mean,
especially prolife, it's a huge issue for
me at, he had just a few years earlier,
said he was pro choice.
He didn't seem to emulate any of the
conservative or Christian values that I
hold in my life.
But then I looked at Hillary Clinton and
I looked at how I felt like the country
was torn apart by Barack Obama over the
past eight years. And I was like, okay,
someone who is going to probably advocate
for legislation and surround himself
with people that aligns more with
my values or someone who I think is
diametrically opposed policywise
to everything I believe.
So I chose him and I think I would
choose him again because again, I,
not that I would ever vote Democrat
and I've never been on the left,
but if I were,
say I were a centrist,
I would be looking over to
the left and saying, okay,
this guy don't like what he
says don't like his personality.
I think he's too brash and
sometimes he doesn't make any sense.
He calls Tim Cook Tim Apple. Okay.
Yeah. Like he's a little embarrassing.
But then I will get people who are
advocating for late term abortion,
open borders and socialism and I'm like,
oh,
like my babies and my private property.
I think I'm going to stick with Trump.
And so yeah,
I'm even more so in that camp because
I am a conservative and I do care about
the future of the country
and I hate socialism,
so of course I'm going
to vote for him again.
And I think that's how a lot of people
feel sometimes a hard case to make.
Yeah, that's how I see it. I mean,
it's like if you guys could
just not be that bananas,
they can then the refugees who
wouldn't do it leaving you,
but you just can't not
be completely insane.
No, they give us something here. Well,
sometimes I wonder if it's a strategy.
Are they taking us to the nth degree?
Are they taking us to the,
the most crazy marks isn't that they can
actually take us. Are they taking us to,
for example,
medicare for all,
just so we'll get on board
with health care for all.
Are they taking us to open borders just
so we'll be okay with abolishing ice?
Are they taking us to,
you know,
killing babies outside of the
womb to where we can say, okay,
as long as it's limited the second
trimester because I, I mean,
I don't think that's going to work,
but I do wonder,
are you guys pushing us to the limits?
So we'll settle for something a little
bit less, but that's still liberal.
I Dunno. Yeah. I mean,
I suppose that could, well, you know,
I don't know what the answer is,
but I suppose they could be doing, I mean,
Trump does a little of that, right? Yeah.
Take out something really far
and then you come in. I mean,
that's what negotiations are
about. Yeah. I don't know.
But watching these guys go off the deep
end has been quite something. And I,
so I mentioned to you a couple of
days ago on a, on Twitter. So I,
you've been hitting the AOC pretty
hard and I think your arguments,
you never attack her personally.
You always go for policy or for the
context of what she's talking about.
Yeah. Um, tell me a little bit about
why you're not thrilled with AOC.
Well, we hear a lot of people in
the last sane, oh, AOC gets tea all,
she's really getting into y'all and she
really bothers you. And I'm like, yes,
she really does. I'm not even
going to pretend like she does.
It especially bothers me.
She's specially bothers me because
she is representative of millennials,
which she isn't really,
but she's representative of
the stereotypes of millennials
and she's a woman and
so she is claiming to represent all
millennials and all women and she is
espousing and saying everything
that is so diametrically opposed,
not only to what I believe in,
but what is good for America.
And also like she just says dumb things.
Just dumb.
It's not that okay. She's crazy.
Like I think Bernie Sanders is crazy,
but I think he's probably smart.
Like he can make a pretty good argument.
She just isn't good. She's not even
good at fulfilling her own arguments.
And I think it's her.
It's the hypocrisy to of saying,
well no one has any
legitimate concerns with me.
No one has any legitimate criticism.
I'm going to pull this random tweet from
this person with pin followers and say,
well, this is all of the right, making
fun of my shoes. This is all they've got.
Well,
no,
there's been a lot of people asking you
for dialogue and debate and to discuss
ideas and policies and you refuse to,
that's what bothers me.
Yeah. So what do we do about that? Because
the energy of the media, the focus,
so much of it is on her. I agree. I
don't think she's particularly bright.
I think she has handlers that
at times are writing her.
She's not writing most of these
tweets. Yes, maybe she types them out,
but it's very clear if you listen to
her speak the way she speaks and her
understanding of
information is very loose.
And then in Twitter form,
she knows all these things about history
and policy and all of these things and
the idea that she wrote the
green deal or any of that stuff,
it's just all nonsense.
But what do you do if so
much of the energy is focused
there? Um, which, which I,
you know, I think we're in
agreement. It's dangerous.
How do you move that if she won't debate?
Yeah,
I think the all you can do is advocate
for your own policies and ideas the best
way that you can. And yes, of
course, to call out her lies and say,
this is why it's a lie. I mean,
you might not convince everyone,
but maybe there is one person who thought
that her tweet was awesome and looked
at what you said and said,
okay,
well maybe now I am starting to
see a pattern of not just her,
but people like her that use
identity politics and use, uh,
this victimhood narrative. Someone
like Ilhan Omar as well to say, Oh,
you can't criticize me.
I'm seeing that a lot.
Maybe her credibility comes into question.
So I do think that's important.
I think it's important to keep it
above board as much as we can with the
criticisms. Now I'm not necessarily good
at that. Like sometimes I just want to,
yeah. And I don't, I
don't want to call it,
I mean I don't think I ever go for
anything super personal or ad Hominine,
but there are times where I just want
to be like, this girl's an idiot.
She's an idiot. And I don't think that
that's probably just to call myself out.
I don't think that's the
most productive thing to do.
We should probably say why she's wrong.
Um,
but someone who I think is actually
trying to play her same game, um,
it's a little bit different
cause he's older and he's a man,
but Dan Crenshaw is using social media
to his benefit to actually talk about
what's going on in Congress. Say, here's
the legislation I'm trying to get past.
Here's what the Democrats are doing,
here's the back and forth fight.
We have hardly any transparency
in Congress from the right.
We don't have a young
representative that saying, okay,
this is what you're hearing.
Here's what's actually happening.
AOC is trying to do that.
But you do have someone like Dan Crinshaw
who's trying to do it on our side and
I think that's important.
What do you think is the goal of this
new crop of Democrats? Like do you like,
to me,
they genuinely want to change every
fundamental law and every fundamental
philosophy that is underpinned this
country for over 200 years. Really,
it sounds alarmist,
it sounds conspiratorial,
but I think they're deeply on
proud of what America is. Yeah. Um,
and it's very sad for me, as we
talked about right before we started,
it's like this ain't the
party at JFK anymore.
Right? It was one thing when
we just disagreed on policy.
It's another thing when
we disagree on patriotism,
it's when we disagree that fundamentally
America was founded on good ideas.
Maybe you don't like the
founder founding fathers,
maybe you don't even like
that they owned slaves.
Maybe you think that America has a bad
history. We can probably agree on that,
that America doesn't
have a perfect history,
but us not agreeing on
basic constitutional values
of individual liberty,
of the rates that are
endowed to us by our creator.
That creates a whole
other host of problems.
We have not more complicated
disagreements between this new crop,
but a more fundamental disagreements,
more simple disagreements
than we've ever had before.
That's what makes them so
frustrated. And, and people like me,
like us who care about American values
and are down with the constitution,
it's really kind of mind boggling.
Like we don't even know where to
take their arguments sometimes.
But when you look at what's
coming out of academia,
I mean all this postmodern garbage,
it kind of makes sense.
I mean they've been taught that America
is this imperialist aggressor in
everywhere. Boots have been on American
boots had been on the ground. Uh,
evil has spread and white nationalism
has spread. That's what they're learning.
And you're like, okay, I
can see where they got that.
It's sad because it's an accurate.
Um,
but I think that's kind of where it's
coming from and that's what they're
promulgating.
Yeah. Are there parts of their
right that you're not happy with?
Definitely. I mean, if the alt
rate is even still a thing,
I feel like it's kind of had its heyday.
I literally prayed that it's had.
Of course I don't like them. I think
there are a bunch of Internet trolls.
There are people also
who think that the world,
the West is going to be
one back through memes.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with me and the other all cause means no,
I don't think there's
anything wrong with that,
but I don't think that's
primarily where the,
where the battle is fought and then I
do get frustrated with people who can't
ever criticize Trump when he says things.
For example,
and this was a while ago saying,
okay,
we'll take away their guns and then due
process or something like that or where
they can't refute him on trade,
they can't push back at him at all.
Or they try to paint him into
like this almost Demi God savior.
That bothers me because, okay,
let's not pretend that he's Ronald.
He might've even done better things
than Ronald Reagan in a lot of ways,
but let's not pretend that who
he is as a man is Ronald Reagan,
that he represents all of our conservative
values. I think it's okay to say,
you know what,
as a Christian,
I don't really agree with a
lot of things that he says.
A lot of the things that he's done.
I still like his policies,
but I'm just going to be honest.
I don't love everything that he's done.
The people that will not say that
that bothers me, I just don't get it.
Do you think that there's a like
sort of a sickness around the cult of
personality related to our politicians?
The way we talk about them
and think about them. I mean,
so you could take that with
Trump from certain people,
you know the certain just diehard mag
of people who would never find fault and
you could take that
with the obsession with,
oh there's better with
his shirt rolled up,
stand and auditable and skateboarding
and just the way we talk about them,
like they're all celebrities or the that
they have the where with all to fix all
our problems.
It all actually feels gross to me.
Like politics feels very gross to me for
someone that talks about it as much as
I should.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's because it's gotten
so dramatize that it almost feels like
our favorite soap opera.
You know how someone has a character
that they just love and can do no wrong.
They're like, I'm, I'm fighting
for this person in this show.
It's almost that are our politics
have become so celebritize,
which really almost started with Barack
Obama and so dramatize that people have
picked their favorite characters and
they feel like they have to pick one and
there's, there's no wait. Yeah,
there's no way that they're
going to pick the other one.
But I also think it has to do with the
fact that they see their enemy as so bad,
as so crazy as so radical and the left
is beating up on Trump so much and so
unfairly that they,
I think they're honestly thinking
and maybe with good intentions.
Why would I pile on that? Sure. Maybe I
don't like some of the stuff that he does,
but we never hear any of
the good that he does.
So I'm going to be a part of the group
that talks about the good that he does
and not the bad. So maybe,
maybe those intentions are pure.
Yeah. So I, I do agree with that.
I think that there's a certain set of
people that think, well wait a minute,
this guy is relentlessly getting
attacked and lied about and Russia
investigations and everything else. So
when he says something like to me, the,
the one that you hit on a there,
we'll take away the guns first
and then the due process. To me,
that probably is the worst thing that he
has said in, in the two plus years. Yeah.
And I could see why a decent person that
would know that that's wrong wouldn't
go crazy about it because a,
he probably was probably just like
sloppy language maybe. Right. Maybe,
but B, it's like everyone's attacking the
guy constantly. Like cut him some slack.
But I guess it,
there's a danger in that too.
Yeah. And I think it's that they look
at his actions, they keep saying,
or I should say we,
we look at his actions like,
do I think that he is
ideologically prolife?
Do I think he really cares about abortion?
Probably not now.
Maybe he's been awakened to
like a lot of people have,
but the New York law and Virginia bail
that didn't get passed and said, okay,
that's really bad,
but I don't really care what he
personally thinks about abortion.
He's been a a prolife advocate
and I think that's a good thing.
And I want him to advocate for
the things that I believe in.
And I always knew when I was always
pretty confident in the fact that even if
he's not an idealogue,
which I think we all knew that he wasn't,
he was going to surround himself by
people that would push the values in the
policies that conservatives
believe in him. That's nowadays,
that's really all I care abouts.
Almost all. I wouldn't say all,
but that's most of what I care
about it enough to get my vote.
So is that the irony I guess for Christian
conservatives is that you needed a
guy that was going to do a play,
a dirty game,
and maybe you couldn't get
Romney or McCain. Yeah, I
mean tried it the other way,
like those guys weren't going to play
in such a way because it's not just that
you're fighting the candidate,
you're also fighting the
media establishment in
the colleges and all that.
That's not how I thought of it because
I didn't vote for him in the primaries.
In Lichen,
in the primaries,
I actively talked about not
voting for him in the primary.
Do you make or what's the,
the onslaught against Christians
because I talk about it,
I talk about it pretty frequently on,
on Twitter and here and I'm not Christian,
but I see what's going on and it's,
yeah,
this is now the state sanctioned bigotry.
Yeah. That's okay. Not quite staid,
but like, yeah, if you care about
what the media is allowed, you know,
you can always attack white Christian
man. Totally. They're all homophobes in,
they're all big bigots and
all of this nonsense. Yeah.
And I go to events with these people all
the time and I find them to be decent
and respectful and willing to disagree
and walk away without punching you and
everything else. But what do
you make of just like the focus?
Yeah. On that? Well, it's part of,
it's part of intersectionality.
You posted the quiz the
other day that it was like,
what's your intersectionality score?
Intersectionality scores. Yes.
And one of the things that you could
slide was whether or not you're a devout
Christian.
The more devout of a Christian you are,
I guess the more privileged Dui or the
lower you are in the intersectionality
scale or something like that.
And so I think it's just associated
because America and the West, uh,
why is driven by,
uh,
by Christianity and what's driven
specifically by Protestants. I mean,
the revolutionary war was seen as a
Presbyterian and rebellion and a lot of
those people line anything with anything
that is aligned with Americanism is
white nationalists is wrong,
is imperialist. Christianity
gets tied up in that.
Now for Evangelical Christians,
we also know,
because the Bible tells us that the
Church of Christ is going to be pushed to
the margins until the world comes to
an end. And so we will be persecuted,
we will, uh, be more and
more marginalized am yes,
we can continue to fight
for Christian values.
We continue to fight for being left alone
really is what we're really fighting
for.
Just kind of leave us alone.
That's what Protestants pretty much
have always done. Um, but yeah,
I mean at the,
at the end of the day,
we know that it's not going
to end well for us probably.
Yeah. It's really crappy
situation. Like every day,
just another tweet and another
story, this nonsense, you know,
they'll do Chris Pratt church and
they'll try to make it seem like, oh,
he's a homophobe and he goes, this
homophobic church and it's like, guys,
you want to do a lot Omar's mosque,
now you want to do that.
But they don't want to do that because
actually they're the bigots. Right.
That really is the truth.
Yeah. And that's the thing is that
they're fine. They're really fine.
The left is fine with you being a
Christian as long as you don't actually
believe what the Bible says.
So as long as you believe the
stuff about feeding the poor,
as long as you believe that kind of stuff.
But that has to mean the government,
they got rid of it. Feeding right,
right. Is longer. You're down with that,
but you have to take
away the wrath of God.
You had to take away Jesus be
the only way, truth and life.
You have to take away the
biblical marriage stuff.
You have to take away the abortion
stuff if to take away the hard work that
proverbs talks about that even the
apostle Paul talks about kind of take all
that away.
As long as you're the Christian that
believes in wealth redistribution,
you're good.
Yeah. That word. So let's dive
into some of the topics of the day.
You mentioned the uh, the wage
gap. Yeah, it was recently.
It was, what was it, gender
pay, gap day or Hashtag
you're so privileged you don't
even let her know our day.
Even though I just made sure to pay
all my female plays less that day. Oh,
just really drive it home. Yeah. Um,
is it a myth what's going on here?
It's a myth because,
well, it's partly a math.
What they don't tell you is the entire
story is this whole uncontrolled gap
through our versus the controlled gap.
And I actually heard about that
originally on a more left leaning site.
That's an organization up in Seattle that
fights for equal pay and they actually
taught me on their site the difference
between an uncontrolled gap and a
controlled gap
toward a great Twitter
thread on this by the way,
which we'll link to in the description.
Yeah. Yeah. It was the
control the gap, um,
account or I'll start with
the uncontrolled gap. Does
not account for job title,
doesn't account for experiences
and account for hours work.
It really doesn't put any factors
in. It's just the median, uh,
what women make versus the median, what
men make, which is 79 cents to a dollar.
That is true,
but it doesn't account for any choices
or an experience that controlled gap
accounts for all of those things.
So it accounts for job title hours worked,
all of that. It does it account for, uh,
like negotiating a raised as an account
for end of year bonuses or anything like
that.
But it does account for the big factors
and that is 99 cents on the dollar.
So women make 99 cents to every
dollar that a man makes. But again,
you're not accounting for a few factors
there and that could be within the
margin of error.
So no matter what,
there is no proof that there is
systemic sexism that is causing women,
uh,
to make less money.
Well,
it also doesn't account for the fact that
men and women choose different careers
at the most simple level.
I mean,
the best example of this is Sweden where
they have been completely egalitarian
for ever.
Basically,
I guess what there is still more male
engineers and there's still more female
versus,
yeah.
So now they want to like force people to
do things that they don't actually want
to do so they can get it 50 50 which yeah,
I'm not really a freedom work.
No. And there's, I mean
there's a million different
programs to try to get women into stem
because they've said for so long that the
reason why there are so many
more men in stem is because, uh,
women feel intimidated and because there's
this patriarchal attitude in the stem
field, while so they've tried
so hard, they put so much
money behind it and still,
I mean men are outpacing women or there
are so many more men in stem. The, I mean,
just as many as there's ever been.
And so it's probably not 80 outside
factors probably because women in general
are different. How much of this
do you think is just misguided?
Sort of confusion. So for
example, you're pregnant,
your husband's here in the green room,
your career is there going
to be a little bit different.
But if you're going to probably take
some time off to it, child rear, yeah.
Maybe he will take some maternity
time. Maybe not. But yeah,
that just physiologically
we just are different.
They don't like talking
about that. Yeah. Um,
but that is just the nature of reality.
I saw a study the other day that it was
like breaking news and it was some study
out of the UK that showed that there
is a difference between boys and girls
brains inside the womb. That
is, uh, is it early as you know,
however many weeks gestation that a
child's brain is developing and they start
going in these divergent paths
of women, um, the, just the,
how the neurons connected,
women kind of being grown into
these interpersonal creatures,
whereas men are more focused in
general on objects and data and things.
Women are more focused on ideas and
words and people that starts in the womb.
And I'm like,
I'm so glad science is finally catching
up to God and finally catching up to the
things that we've known
for thousands of years.
And so you do wonder if that's
going to happen? If, okay,
we're trying all of these cool social
experiments right now. Like maybe, oh,
maybe it'll be fine if we draft women.
Like maybe it'll be fine if we just
pretend we just are totally gender neutral
with our kids and pretend like no
binary definition of gender exists. Um,
but I do wonder if science will
catch up with us and be like,
actually all these things
that conservatives were
saying that the left dot we're
social constructs,
they're just biological reality.
Well,
they also made find out what if they found
out that there was a gay gene one day?
Yeah. Now they're pro choice. Would you,
you have to be okay then with a
woman deciding to abort that baby
because they don't want
the child to be gay.
And that does put them in this
kind of ethical conundrum. I mean,
but it's the same thing
with, with race. I mean,
I guess you would know what race your
child is obviously before you had an
ultrasound or anything like
that. But, uh, you have, I mean,
there is a racial aspects to abortion
and that the majority of abortions happen
in minority communities. And so when
you ask a pro choice or about that,
they don't typically have
any kind of answer though.
Wage gap. Uh, you briefly mentioned
the trends situation or gender roles.
Yeah. The trends issue for
considering it's, you know,
0.01% of the population or something.
And I have complete sympathy yeah.
With the issues that they're dealing
with a little overblown in our national
discussion.
Yes.
And I think that the left does that a lot.
Maybe I'm going to give them
the benefit of the doubt.
Maybe with good intentions because
people with gender dysphoria,
it truly is a struggle.
I know someone with gender dysphoria and
it is a struggle. They didn't want this,
they didn't,
they don't like this kind of struggle of
feeling like they don't belong in their
own body. It really is a psychological
struggle, but you treat it as a struggle.
You treat it as something that,
okay,
we don't just say while live what you
want to live because they actually,
the rates of suicide are pretty
much equal afterwards. Um,
it doesn't actually reconcile
anything when we say, okay,
just do what you want to do because it
truly is it disorder in a dysphoria. Um,
and I think maybe in an attempt to be
compassionate to the people that are
dealing with this and to help them
not feel ashamed that left who said,
you know what,
we're just going to validate who you are.
I personally don't think
that's the compassionate thing
to do, to lie to someone.
And I know a lot of conservatives
feel the same way. Um,
but then you do start finding yourself
getting angry and defensive about a
subject that we should have a lot of
sympathy for because people force you to
use gender pronouns that
you don't want to use a,
they force you to have conversations
that you don't want to have.
And that's where things
just get really sticky.
And that's when unfortunately
conservatives including me,
we get really dogmatic about it and the
sympathy and compassion is thrown out
the window.
Yeah.
So what do you do to fight that?
Cause that I get that it's tough if you
just keep being called to transfer over
or any of these phobes well
eventually you're just like,
all right then enough of this I'm
going to go for the destroys tweet and
scattered the compassion tweet.
Well the tweets are difficult
because the tweets is like
you only have so many
characters and putting out the
nuanced compassionate tweet
is typically not what comes to mind.
I think when you're just trained to
put your, put your idea out there,
you don't have time to add.
The new ones are like,
I'm just going to get to the
point I want saying that's right.
But that's typically my tendency and
our tendency and I don't think that's a
good thing.
But in conversations I always think it's
really important to define your terms.
If you have a same leftist who was
saying you're a trans folk. Okay,
well we need to define phobia and we
need to define what I believe in what you
believe and maybe we actually
agree on a lot of the same things.
We just disagree on the facts.
We just disagree on the variables.
So I think defining
the terms is important.
It starting with what you
agree is important. Uh, and
then working out from there.
How often do we do that?
Maybe not enough.
Would you, do you think it's fair to
say that the average conservative, well,
first off, you know, the, the, when they
keep putting fold at the end of the world,
phobe is an irrational fear.
So I assume you don't think
that the average conservative
has an irrational fear
of trans people, right? No, I
don't think so. Okay. So what,
what do you think the average,
do you think the average PR, uh,
conservative has the thoughts
that you laid out earlier,
which is sort of a sympathy for this,
but then we don't want that to override
our thinking brains on there like that.
I think some people are
saying you don't want,
I really don't care if
you dress like a girl.
Are you dressed like a guy or you
want to call yourself something? Um,
I just don't want you to force that on me.
I don't want you to take away,
for example, my religious liberty
in lieu of like I, I, I don't know,
they don't want their rights trampled
upon in favor of this small group.
Uh,
however,
I do think there are people that kind
of see where this line of reasoning goes
that if, okay, we denied
biological realities,
we deny what science is telling us and
we buy into this delusion that a man can
just wake up one day and
say that he is a woman,
then okay we kind of lose, we kind of
lose all truth. What is truth anymore?
It's just what you feel. We lose
identity. It's just who you say you are.
Or are you actually defined in any way
by biology and I think they see the kind
of slippery slope that goes down and
they say, okay, stop right there.
I'm not down with this.
Did you all sounds crazy to just wake
up and you know, middle age and be like,
well now email. But it's
like at that point, I mean
this is, this sounds bananas,
but if you were a washed up
male NBA player, good and
play in the league anymore,
you can be like, yeah, I'm a woman
today. I identify as woman, right? Yeah,
I'm jumping in then WMV and I'm
going to be the MVP. Watch this,
and then the feminist would have to
say, yeah, your lived experience.
Yeah. Well that's the other problem with
it is that you're kind of seeing some
feminists pushback on this
and say, hang on. Well,
old school feminist have
been kind of saying, okay,
we fought for the uniqueness of women,
the empowerment of women because women
are women and now men are beating us at
our own. Gay Men are better at being
women. Then women are, that's not fair.
And so I do think you see
feminist pushing back on that,
who truly do believe that.
Okay.
The reason why we fought for the
empowerment of women is because women are
unique. Only women can have children.
Only women can do certain things.
Women are better at some things than
men are. As far as leadership goes.
As far as organization goes,
things like that.
And they fought to bring
those things to the forefront.
And now none of those things matter
anymore because you can be a man to be a
woman. So there is just, I'm
just so glad I'm not on the lot.
It just seems so confusing.
That's quite miserable. It is. All right,
so your Prager u video make men masculine
again. Why did they have a man do that?
Why did they have a, what was the
idea? We're going to have a woman. Yes.
Talk about male,
male masculinity.
I think it's because you're seeing a lot
of women talk about how terrible toxic
masculinity is and say, Oh man, they just,
they don't even know how hard today
today's in. David pressed us for so long,
we just need them to take a back seat
and so we can kind of step up and do our
thing. And so I think they wanted
the perspective of a woman to say,
hang on just a second. Women actually
do, not only do we like masculine men,
um, or not even necessarily
traditional masculinity.
I'm not talking about like
riding a four wheeler,
I'm talking about taking responsibility
for your actions and taking care of your
family.
I'm taking care of that provision and
protection that men are so good at it.
And I think better at than women are.
So you could still wear a
nice shirt, let's say. Yes,
you should be able to take care of it.
Yeah. It's more internal
traits than anything else.
And the actions and the habits that you
have, the responsibilities that you take,
women do care about it.
Actually,
the complimentarian relationship
that men and women have had for ever,
um, has, has worked really well.
It's worked really well. Not always.
I mean sometimes it goes over to
a patriarchy and that's not good.
I don't think oppression of women is
good, but the, the ying and the Yang,
the back and forth and uh,
the complimentarian relationship
that we've had has worked.
And I think you kind of needed
to hear a woman say that.
So why do you think the
left's trying to destroy that?
Because they think egalitarian
is a more equal equality.
So it's equality through homogeny,
which is part of why abortion is a
really big thing that they fight for.
If a man can physically walk
away from an unwanted pregnancy,
oh woman should be able
to too. I mean, pregnancy,
the ability to get pregnant is really one,
not one of the only things,
but probably the biggest thing
that makes a woman different.
And so if we get rid of that through
abortion and then maybe men and women
really well be the same and
maybe they really will be equal,
then there'll be no abuse, no oppression,
no patriarchy, things like that.
But I mean men are always going to be
physically stronger than women and there's
always going to be bad men and bad women.
So oppression won't stop.
Abuse won't stop. Egalitarianism
is just going to make, or not,
I shouldn't say egalitarianism,
but sameness is going to make
things more confusing, not better.
So I know you do a public speaking too,
and when you go to colleges,
do you find you have any
tricks on how to wake up,
say some of the lefties
that are, you know, at least
open to some of these ideas,
but they're kind of like,
oh, she must be the bad guy,
but I'll at least go and
sit in the back of the room.
Well,
what I try to do is I try to,
my messages typically when I can
usually speaking to mostly conservative,
it's a is that okay,
you're hearing that you're crazy for
believing and things like border security
for being pro life,
for being pro capitalism.
But here's where these ideas come from
and here's how they have worked and
really only over the past 10 to 15
years have we heard all of this crazy
intersectionality,
identity politic stuff that they
are acting like his main stream.
And so you're not the extremist,
you're not the radical,
you're not the one that's out there.
You're not the Nazi and the bigot.
You believe things that Americans have
believed since our founding and they have
a really good history
and a really good basis.
And so I don't know if that has
necessarily ever changed a leftist mind,
but it is something that's different
than just talking points and saying the
left is stupid. It's saying, hey,
we have good ideas and you have a right
to believe they're good ideas and you
have a right to defend these
good ideas. Um, really the,
the most disrespectful or the craziest.
I always get very respectful,
great liberal students that come and
listen and ask awesome questions.
I think the only time that has been like,
oh my gosh,
I can't even get a word out without these
people screaming is when I was at UC
Berkeley and I spoke to or done that.
Yes.
And I spoke to a class and the professor
was awesome for asking me and I
actually thought when I went in
there, I was like, I'm gonna,
I gotta be really tame. I'm going
to be really tame with what I say.
I'm not going to say I'm not gonna
throw any flames or anything like that.
Oh my gosh, I couldn't even, it was like
they had never heard a conservative idea.
They'd never heard, uh,
someone who wasn't a liberal,
utter a word and it was irrational.
It was irrational.
That was really my only experience
where I was like, this is crazy.
They've abandoned thought.
Do you in a weird way, blame the baby
boomers for this cause it's their kids,
right? Like, or it's the end of there.
The young end of their children,
like sort of weird way.
You can't blame the,
the 16 year old who now gets into college,
you know, a couple of years go by,
he's been indoctrinated in high school,
gets to college,
gets slammed with more of this
stuff. I have sympathy for him. Well,
when they're yelling at me,
I don't have that much sympathy for them.
But like I have sympathy
for that condition because
they were just thrown into
that. Um, we're not that you're
looking to blame somebody,
but if you had to sort of figure
out where this whole thing started,
where would you go?
Well,
it's the baby boomers really like to
talk about how terrible millennials are.
And I agree with them to some degree.
I mean a lot of the stereotypes
that people have of us stare, uh,
entitled and apathetic or true,
but I remind them like we were raised,
we were raised by someone,
we weren't raised by wolves and I don't
think it's so much that parents probably,
um, told their kids to be entitled
or told their kids to be spoiled.
I don't know if it was a lack of
values that were taught in the family,
but also there was a significant change
from the time our parents were kids.
Like my mom for example, was, you know,
she was driving to the liquor store to
get her dad beer when she was like 13
years old. I mean, car seats, like
that just wasn't even a thing. I mean,
everything was a lot more free
to the time where we were kids.
I remember there was like a new law that
said you have to be in a car seat until
you're like in second grade or
something like that. Everything changed.
Everything became more safe and everything
shifted from like the latch key kids
who were coming home and
fending for themselves.
That's mostly generation x because both
their parents had jobs to kind of these
helicopter parents and these,
everybody gets a trophy or this,
everybody gets a trophy
mentality that we had in school.
It's not like we didn't have competition,
but it was the,
everyone gets some kind of reward. I
would know. I'm terrible at running.
I'm so slow and yet in every race
and I thought I got honorable,
honorable mention, I got something
and that's how we were raised.
I swear to God, so I'm, I'm Gen x so
I'm a little old, but I swear to God.
I remember being in third or
fourth grade field day and I was,
I was a scrawny little kid.
I was not a good athlete.
I became a good athlete later and I
remember getting a slip at field day.
I did not place,
I didn't get a medal and I
remember getting some sort
of participation thing and
I'm not kidding.
I remember as a third or fourth grader
thinking this is nonsense. Like,
why would you give me this? I felt
shitty. I felt bad. I sucked it. Whatever.
We were doing like a slow
bike race and I sucked.
So why didn't any of that yet?
We've,
we've sold this as if this
is how it's supposed to be.
Yeah, I think, I mean it's parenting.
It's technology, its values, its purpose,
so much.
I mean you do also,
you can't deny just the effect the
personal technology had on millennials.
And we had iPhone from the time that we
were probably 15. We had cell phones.
Even before that we had my space.
Zenga if anyone remembers that you guys
face, oh, I think it was before my today.
I didn't have it, but I remember some
people did. You had AOL instant messenger.
So you had personalized technology from
a really young age that told us that
everything is about you. Um,
everything is focused on you.
And then the older that we got, we
got Netflix, we've got Uber eats,
we got all of these things that
made life really convenient.
Instant gratification. Always. We
don't know anything other than Amazon.
I don't know how to
read a map like I don't.
I remember my dad tried to teach me how
to read a map in high school. I was like,
yeah, dad. Okay.
I remember that a map is had to refold it.
The rest it's like whatever,
but you can just fold it
back in the way it came out.
Well, I don't even know how to do that.
So, and I think most millennials don't,
and so this instant gratification things
should be easy for me as they are in
the technological world has
really affected our politics too.
Do you feel that the technological part
of this has actually really screwed up a
generation then like that?
There's obviously a lot of goodness and
we're doing this on youtube. Yeah, yeah.
All of that. But that it really like
we have where we handed everybody,
it didn't matter what age you are.
We all got handed this
incredible technology that
opened the world, our heads,
but especially if you're a 15 year
old being handed that. Yeah, that's,
that's a lot to give a kid.
Yeah.
I want to hesitate to blame
all of all of it on technology.
I also see a loss of values and that
we're not only the most progressive
generation, but we're also the
most irreligious generation.
We're the biggest generation of religious
nones in o n e s and I do think a lot
of us are wandering looking for truth,
not really knowing what that is. Not me,
but a lot of people in our generation.
I don't know if that comes with
technology at all or if that's connected,
but it's certainly a factor and why you
think millennials just don't have any
center. They don't have any grounding
and they just think that their center is
themselves. They were told this
all the time on social media.
I mean your favorite fitness blog or your
favorite self help author is just love
yourself. If you just look
in the mirror in the morning,
you tell yourself you're awesome,
that you're enough,
then you're going to be fine
and that's what you need to do.
Everything's about my happiness. So you
cut out the toxic people in your life,
you cut out the things
that you don't like,
the things that make you sad and you
just do, you can be pretty lonely.
Yeah. I mean there's, right and w I mean,
what do you do when
the self love runs out?
What do you do when the
self esteem runs out?
What do you do when you wake up in
the morning and you're like, okay,
I'm not that awesome and I
haven't accomplished that much.
Should you just continue to
coddle yourself? Or should
you do something about it?
In the millennial is told cuddle,
you'll be flying and then you have
someone like AOC saying, well,
we're going to provide economic security
for people who are unwilling to work.
And so if you just want to
be, uh, a watercolor painter,
even if you suck at it,
you should just doing it.
Yeah. So that's where a lot of money
in watercolor painting generally,
I wouldn't know because I'm not good
at it yet. But, um, I can imagine
gay marriage, let's talk about
it from a Christian perspective.
So when we're posting this, uh, we're
holding this video for a couple of days,
but I just had a Shapiro
right here and yeah,
we've talked about gay marriage and he
talks about his feelings from it Orthodox
Jewish perspective.
And we can,
we've basically gotten it to the place
where we agree to disagree and well,
we agree to disagree on the,
on the fact that he's not okay with
it through a religious perspective,
but he's not trying to legislate my
life and I as a citizen of this country,
I'm completely okay with that. Yeah, I
suspect that's probably similar to yours.
It is similar now as a Christian,
there is a little bit of,
um,
I would say a second layer to that.
So he obviously believes
that homosexuality is wrong
because the old testament
says it. We believe it, not
just because the old testament,
but it's reiterated in the New Testament.
And then there is this crazy picture
in metaphor that is given to us in
Ephesians five that says,
okay,
marriage is a reflection of what
Christians called Christ in the Church as
Christ is the head of the church.
So the husband is the head of the wife,
and so it's this,
um,
husbands are to love their wives as
Christ loves the church and wives are
supposed to submit to their
husbands as to the Lord.
So that there is this spiritual component.
There's gospel component to marriage
being between a man and a woman.
So there really is no theological
way for any Christian. They try,
but to get out of the
dynamic that God set up,
not just biologically and physically,
but also spiritually.
And so that's where I stand as
far as your religious perspective.
Now I've heard both sides of it.
I have heard conservatives and even
libertarians and that I respect saying,
you know what?
I just can't get behind a,
I just can't get behind gay marriage
from even a civics perspective or from a
legal perspective. You heard Libertarians
make that argument? I've heard that.
I've heard liberty here.
I would say not anyone famous.
I would say friends who
probably have libertarian views
still say maybe that was,
maybe they don't feel that way anymore.
But just say it's so hard for me to
separate the personal from the political,
but where I stand politically
is probably the same.
I would say probably the same
place as Ben dies. I mean,
one gay marriage is here to stay.
There's nothing that's going to be
done about it. And I don't think I,
or probably any other evangelical in
the political world is going to fight
against it.
But I think
does that tell you quickly about
the evangelicals in general?
Because I think this is important.
I've, I've said this many times,
but it's like nobody cares
about gay marriage anymore
really in the big picture.
Like I get your, your theological,
yeah. Personal belief,
but in the public political space,
yeah.
Something that was anathema to this
group of people for a long time now has
become normalized pretty quickly,
I think. I think by and large,
Christians have realized that their
communities aren't getting worse,
that the neighbors next door have
kids and they're the same as else.
That you don't even hear Mike
Huckabee going on about it
anymore. Or, or, or, um, uh,
Rick Santorum or any of these guys.
They've sort of moved on.
And I think this is where I would love
the progressive's to have a little
humility. Yeah. Like just a
little bit of, you know what me,
maybe you guys were wrong,
right? You were wrong,
but then something happened and
you let it go. Yeah. Basically.
And that would show a little humanity
and humility and they just refused to do
that. Yeah. And again,
this is where then I can
find myself building bridges
with you guys all the time
because, yeah. Because there's
a place to build the bridge to.
Yeah.
I think that a lot of evangelical
conservatives realized,
okay,
yes,
America was founded on Christian values
and we should continue to perpetuate
those Christian values.
But the state does not define marriage.
God defines marriage. And I think that,
uh, churches should it be free to say,
sorry, we're not gonna, we're not going
to marry two men. You know, and I agree.
Right. And Yeah. And I
knew that you did. Um,
and I think that we kind of made that
separation and say, and said, okay,
God defines marriage in the Bible.
If I don't want to get on board with
it because I am beholden to God and God
above the state,
then that's fine.
And churches shouldn't be beholden
to the state in that regard either.
And I think that we kind of
decided, okay, that's fine.
If they want to get married according
to the state's definition of marriage,
that's okay,
but I in my congregation are not going
to change our views on it and we just
kind of want to be left
alone in that regard.
Yeah. So what would you,
what do you make of when,
when churches do perform
gay marriages? Like, yeah,
we just sort of skirting their
theological honesty or integrity.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
this is a huge thing in the United
Methodist church is that they've kind of
almost had a split because they voted on
this so called traditional plan saying,
okay,
if you're a Methodist church,
if you're under the United Methodist
Church umbrella, this denomination,
you can't perform gay marriage or
you can't, yeah, you can't perform.
You can perform in these marriages.
And there were a lot of people who
are really upset about that. And,
but from a Christian perspective,
you just can't get around it.
There's no way to get,
there's no way theologically to get
around it without making some serious,
not just physical concessions,
but spiritual concessions.
And so my question for anyone,
and it's not just about gay marriage,
it's about anything in the Bible.
My question is,
if you don't take the Bible
as God tells us to take it,
why are you a Christian? Find a different
hobby. Like there's that you can,
you know, you can be a
moral person. You can, yeah,
you can be a good person and you can
believe in feeding the poor without
following Christ.
But Christ tells us to deny yourself,
take up our cross and follow him.
And part of that is adhering to the
word even when it's inconvenient and not
culturally cool.
So I'm just a little bit confused
by those theological concessions.
Um, but yes, to answer your question,
I do think that it's compromising
on what the Bible says.
Yeah. What do you think that would
actually in practice, what does that mean?
You know what I mean?
Like, so in practice,
gay people started getting married now
doesn't matter outside of the church.
What do you think the practice of that
would lead to in society? That would be
all right. Are you talking about
okay. Outside of the church,
so like I understand. Yeah.
Outside of the church,
did you see that some sort of problem?
Well, I, I, I of course do you think
that God's way is better than way?
And I do believe that God's setting up
marriage as a union between a man and a
woman is better. I think
that it's better for, uh,
I think it's better for the family.
I think it's better for children.
And I think because it's better for the
family, it's better for society now.
Do I think it's going to be
the degradation of society?
Do I think that we're,
our whole thing is going to hell in
a hand basket because of that? Uh,
no I don't.
But of course I think that the way God
set up marriage and family and the Bible
is better than how secular
society does it. Um, and yeah,
so that's where I feel
that I feel like we are,
I feel like we'd probably be going.
However,
homosexuality is it different or are
necessarily worse than other sense is a
different kind of sand because it's a
sexual Santa according to Christianity,
but it's not worse.
We don't believe that it puts us in a
worse place than all of the other sense
that America
guys don't let so funny.
I know it's going to happen now,
so people are going to clip this
and there they are going to go out.
See there's Reuben sitting with another
homophobe to his face sitting in his
house where you live, you like hanging
out with homophobe, right? Yeah.
It's just like, I don't, I mean I said
it to Ben, so I'll say to you like,
as long as you're not trying to
legislate my life, I don't care. Yeah.
Maybe there's a part of me that I'm like,
maybe I should care more.
Should I be more offended or something
like that. Yeah. I just don't,
well,
I think part of it too is one,
you want to be left alone like so many
people like Christian has due to go live
your life. Yeah, you want to be
left alone. And I think also,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but a lot of the problem that especially
Christians see on the left is that they
can fleet sexuality with identity.
And so if I disagree with your
relationship from a Christian perspective,
um, then that must mean that I
hate you, but I don't hate you.
I think that you're a great person.
I think you're a smart person and
your husband's awesome. And so they,
a lot of people on the left seem to not
be able to separate those two things.
That I can love you as a person and
respect you and admire you as a person and
not agree from my own Christian
perspective with your relationship. Now,
I also think it's important to say though,
it's not.
If I were to what Christians
would say witness to you,
if I were to share the gospel with you,
it would not be, hey Dave, you're gay.
And that's wrong. That would not be the
message. What we believe that unbelievers,
people who are not Christians are
repenting from when they come to Christ is
unbelief.
It is not your primarily your primary
Santa is that you're gay or that two are a
thief or that you're anything else.
It's that you don't believe in Christ.
And so that's what we believe,
that we are preaching the Gospel
to unbelievers to be saved,
not a gay people to make them straight.
Now we do believe that
through sanctification that
we all have to repent from
our sense. But uh, I think it's
important also to distinguish that,
that what we're talking about salvation
and sharing the gospel with people.
It's not necessarily saying,
uh,
our primary message isn't that
you're gay and that's bad.
Yeah.
But do you think people could just stop
being gay if they repented and stuff?
Well,
I know two different stories.
There is a really good book by someone
who I totally disagree with in so many
ways to somebody in so
many ways. But, uh, she,
she wrote a good book.
Now she probably wouldn't say that.
Oh God makes people straight, but
it's called gay girl. Good God.
It's by Jackie Hill Perry.
And she did live life as a gay person
and then she kind of had an awakening.
She came to God and she's married and she
has kids. There are stories like that,
but I also know stories of people.
Um,
there is another amazing story and I
don't want to say the title because, um,
yeah, I don't want to say the title, but
there is another incredible story of,
of someone who, uh, became a Christian.
He lived life as a gay person.
He actually was in prison,
um,
and he lived life as a gay person and
he became a Christian and he lives,
as far as I know,
he loves a celibate lifestyle.
And so he is not married.
He is probably never going to be married.
He might not ever be attracted to women,
but because he is a Christian and Jesus
has called us to deny ourselves whatever
our desires are that are simple, uh, he
lived a celibate lifestyle. And so I think
just strikes me as deeply sad. Like I can
get it. Yeah. You know, like really like,
you know,
I'm pretty tolerant about this stuff.
Obviously that one just strikes
me as he, he is gay. He,
there is this religious
piece of him in there that,
so the answer is then live alone and
don't have kids and don't have a family.
Yeah.
But that is where you start completing
sexuality with identity and romantic
relationships with the
ultimate fulfillment.
And that's not what the Christian beliefs
actually Paul says for every one is
better to be single than
to be married. Um, he says,
I wish you were all like I was.
So you can be fully dedicated to the Lord
and we believe that if you're straight
or straight or you're same sex attracted,
then the gift of celibacy is truly a
gift that you can dedicate all of your
passions to God. Um, so we
don't see celibacy as this sad,
awful, lonely thing. We believe that
in Christ you have full fulfillment,
full satisfaction, whether
you are attracted to the
opposite sex or the same sex.
And so I think he would tell you great
person to have on, I'll tell you his name,
but,
uh,
I would think he would tell you that he
finds full satisfaction and full of joy
in his relationship with Christ.
Now that does not mean it's easy.
Right?
Well,
I was gonna say he would also sort of
have to say that to rationalize his
existence, right? Like,
May, I don't know, I'd be
happy to have the conversation.
I'm not sure that he would,
I don't think he would have chosen
because he was living in an actively gay
lifestyle. His name's Christopher.
You won. And I think he's incredible.
I don't think he would have chosen
to be a Christian or I don't think he
would've become a Christian. Um, if he
didn't think that was something to it,
if he didn't think that it was worth it.
I mean,
he's seeing the two alternatives
and he chose one direction.
So he obviously thinks that one is
more satisfying than the other. I mean,
he got nothing out of, at least
tangibly in this life saying, okay,
I'm going to give that up and become a
Christian. Yeah. So it makes you wonder,
it does make you wonder. It should
make you wonder about Christianity.
What is it about Jesus that would make
someone give up what they thought their
identity was, where the world
says, well, that's where love is,
is just being yourself and
loving who you want to love.